we're talking to nick offerman whose new
show is called the great
north it's an adult comedy it's on fox
cannot wait
so excited nick i love your opinions on
things and we're gonna play a little
game called
sound offerman
um okay i'm gonna throw out some topics
and
you'll tell us how you feel about them
it'll sound awesome
okay i think i can i can do this game
okay i can't wait all right voice text
when you record
audio of yourself talking and text it to
someone
are so hot right now everyone's doing it
are you doing it i didn't realize that
it was a hot trend
um but i i strongly approve i've been
doing it for years
because i live in los angeles where you
spend
5 8 of your life in your car and so
i'm driving i can't text because i want
to be safe and and live to see tomorrow
so i go for the voice text and say hey
uh dad it's nick i'm sending you this
because i'm driving
don't forget to bring the night crawlers
we will have fun fishing
i love you goodbye it's okay to say i
love you to other men
it's 2021.
[Applause]
yes that is sound offering and dropping
the mic
okay uh this one's personal saying a
friendly hello to strangers but they
ignore you does that ruffle your
feathers funny you should ask drew
um when i go running which i regularly
do
uh in the hills of hollywood i because
i'm from the midwest i
immediately began to wave to people and
greet them
and i would say only about half the
people
will like clock me and respond
and often i really enjoy the response
because it has a sense of
oh i remember this this is
neighborliness yeah
like i forgot about this isn't this from
like the 80s
and the other half now some of them you
know i'm a middle-aged white guy
sometimes i have a big beard
so you know i'd say 15
of the women in a certain age group are
probably right to ignore me
because that's a scary scenario but by
and large there's this weird thing i
think in our society where we have
we have uh let go of the need to be
social and recognize one another um
there there's al also people will be out
walking when i'm running
and they're walking down the street just
full-on yeah
and i'll be like hello and they just
don't they can't even
their their attention doesn't waver from
their device
i'm constantly thinking about the moment
the idea and the fact that we all went
from this
to this and you know what drew i think
they're related i think that
uh i think that our sensibility that
like important things happen inside here
and
uh then the world is virtual that's what
i need to worry about
so if somebody is like over there a real
person is like hey
that's not part of the matrix that i
that i've signed up for
yes and so i think those those things
are related and i think that
you might find that the human being
actually has more is more infinitely
entertaining and and organic and unique
and inspiring
than any app you could ever play
except for candy crush
and i have to admit i do love a good gps
and i love a good shazam but
i think what you just said is really
profound and i love it i'm going to be
thinking about it a lot so
thank you well i love sound offer mining
with you
um and i just think you're so awesome
and i love your wife so much and my
greatest
um love and affection to the both of you
and may we all find ourselves in some
toga gear
as soon as possible that would be a nice
full circle moment
so thank you so much for coming here
today nick
amen to that drew thank you so much it's
great to see you
well be sure to catch the great north
sundays at 8 30 pm
on fox the new fantastic animated adult
show we need these shows they're
fantastic and so are you nick thank you
so much
you